it has been one of the greatest battles
of our time Apple's iOS and Google's
Android attack one side open
customizable welcoming on the other
simplicity security and speed right you
two we're talking about operating
systems not the survival of the human
race yes the smartphone wars have been
fierce but right now feels like the
right time for a peace accord when I
reviewed Apple's iOS 9 a few weeks ago I
said many of the best features came from
Android well here I am reviewing Android
6.0 marshmallow which comes out soon and
many of the best features I've found
come from iOS yes there's still reasons
to choose one over the other but it's
getting real hard to spot the difference
between these two enemies what could we
possibly have in common
four seriously and improved Siri and iOS
9 means getting what you need faster but
Android M does that even better with its
new biggest feature Google now on tap
Google now still feeds you info you want
to the left of the home screen just like
Siri and iOS now but in marshmallow you
can hold down the home button when
looking at a web page email message etc
to jump to the next logical step it's
been great for creating calendar
appointments right from an email and
being able to jump to a menu from a
restaurant mentioned in a message then
it can do stuff like this how old is he
now
he is 21 years old yeah Siri can't do
that
but like Siri Android also suggest apps
you may want to use next base on your
usage instead of giving apps blanket
permission to access all parts of your
phone like your microphone camera and
location you can now specify which apps
get access to what in the settings menu
and like iOS 9 Android M has also
focused on core stability and battery
life improvements I didn't see a better
battery life in my usual battery tests
of the Nexus 5 and 6 but that's because
the savings comes when the phone is on
the table or in a pocket when it's
sleeping some apps won't run in the
background honestly my biggest complaint
about Android marshmallow is it'll take
far too long for new phones from Samsung
and HTC to get it some old phones will
never get it so what does that mean for
you two
well really it's a matter of personal
preference iOS you're still the better
choice for the privacy and security
conscious user looking for simplicity
but your core services are nowhere near
as strong as Google's that's a matter of
opinion an Android your best for those
who love Google services and want custom
options but you've got to work on your
operating system updates and security
whatever now can you two just agree that
you're both great and mature mobile
operating systems with tons of shared
smarts she must be crazy at least we
agree on something